[inaudible]
joining me today is the president of Oklahoma Wesleyan University,
the author of not a daycare,
the devastating consequences of abandoning truth and a staunch defender of
intellectual freedom on campus.
Dr Every Piper,
welcome to the Rubin report.
I'll thank you for having me.
I'm honored to join you today.
I'm glad to have you because you are writing about and talking about and living
many of the ideas that obviously I focus on here.
Before we get to any of that though,
your other book,
your first book,
I want to get the title exactly right cause it's just perfect.
The title is why I'm a liberal and other conservative ideas.
One of the things that I've been saying lately is that defending my liberal
principles is becoming a conservative position and I think that probably sort of
puts us in a similar spot.
W what is liberalism mean to you?
Why?
Why do you consider yourself a liberal?
Well,
I would argue that what you're doing right now,
his is the historic definition of classical liberalism.
Let's go back to the founding of the Liberal Arts Institution.
Let's just say Oxford 1000 years ago.
Why was a liberal Arts Academy established?
It was to educate a free man or free woman,
a free culture,
a free church,
a free people.
It was an education in liberty and education and freedom.
So the classical definition of a liberal was somebody who argued for and
defended human liberty.
And it was in the context of that education,
a liberal arts education that Chesterton told us some 100 years ago that without
fences you don't have freedom enough without honoring the big laws,
you don't have liberty.
So it's this tension within the Liberal Arts Academy of pursuing truth with a
capital t that actually has the paradox of releasing you for the greatest
measure of human liberty,
human freedom in the course of human history.
So a classical liberal liberal as somebody who understands the conservation,
you're a conservationist,
you're conserving those time tested trues that actually work to provide human
liberty.
So you ended on the word work there.
What,
what happened to liberalism?
I mean if you look at it,
if especially through an American context today,
the people that call themselves liberals,
and I'm not really talking about the classical liberals anymore who have far
more in common,
we say Libertarians.
Then progressive's what happened to liberalism?
Because I believe as I think you do,
this is the right set of ideas that the ideas that I'm constantly talking about
about the individual and laissez faire economics and limited government or the
light touch of government.
I think these are really the right ideas to move a free society forward,
and yet what modern liberalism is has almost nothing to do with that.
Let's go back to Richard Weaver in 1948 why did he write his seminal work?
Ideas have consequences.
We hardly even need to crack the cover to understand what he's saying.
They matter.
Good ideas,
good culture,
good kids,
good community,
good country,
good fruit,
good ideas,
bear good fruit and bad ideas have the opposite effect.
Now,
why is 1948 critical in this analogy?
In my answer to you is because weaver was writing to his culture a handful of
years after what the Nazi Holocaust and he was saying,
we should've seen this coming.
We imbibed terrible ideas for decades and we bore the consequences they're in.
So we need to attend to the ideas that have been tested by time,
defended by reason,
proven by experience.
And I would argue as a Christian given by revelation,
it's those permanent ideas.
It's the conservation of those ideas that are big rather than dumbing down the
conversation to the million ideas that are small.
Again,
Chesterton get rid of the big laws and you don't get liberty.
You rather get thousands and thousands of little laws that rush in to fill the
vacuum.
And if him,
if that isn't the definition of our culture today,
I don't know what is.
Yes,
we are overregulated and everyone thinks that there's just another answer that
lies in a law somewhere.
And usually it does.
And so then what do you consider yourself a conservative now then?
Or do these labels even matter to you that much?
Well,
I would say a conservative as somebody who conserves,
okay.
I believe in conserving and I own a tree and clean water and clean air.
But I also believe in conserving something,
perhaps even more important.
And that's ideas,
ideas that work.
Uh,
the Wesleyan quadrilateral,
and it's actually actually Augustinian too.
But let's go back to John and Charles Wesley other misses out 17 hundreds.
They had something they called the quad,
the quadrilateral,
and it was a worldview.
It was the four things that you should sift any idea through as you evaluated
some veracity,
tradition,
reason,
experience,
and scripture.
Revelation,
if you will,
if you want to get outside of the bounds of a Christian Wang,
which we'll call it revelation,
natural law.
Common Sense.
All right,
so tradition,
history,
grandma and grandpa might have actually known something.
The old ideas as cs Lewis said,
are often better than the new ideas.
If you want to read a new book,
fine,
go ahead.
Said Louis.
But you might want to consider reading,
oh,
a dozen or so old ones first.
Why you mean grandma?
Grandpa weren't automatically backwards.
They weren't automatically stupid.
In fact,
and I use that obviously as an analogy,
the old ideas that have been around for a while may be there,
but not necessarily,
but they may be there because they've proven themselves over time.
So history,
tradition,
experience,
it's the Dr Phil Question.
How's that one working for you?
We should always respond to ourselves as we're evaluating our own ideas and our
own worldview as well as our adversary,
or even those that agree with us and say,
how is it working for us?
Is there a pragmatic value to this?
Does it work over time for social health,
personal health,
physical health,
whatever?
Does it work?
So tradition and experience,
reason you've got a brain,
use it.
The rationality,
facts,
feeling.
We're in a culture right now that's dumb down everything to feelings rather than
facts.
Facts be damned.
Yeah,
we're not pro science any longer.
We ignore science for the sake of a political popular agenda.
We're gonna to find to plenty of that.
And then finally,
the fourth component of the quad,
the quadrilateral is revelation.
Those things that are true and it doesn't have to be tested in to,
for example,
uh,
the empiricists,
the materialist would say if he can't taste it,
touch it,
feel it,
see it.
It just isn't.
So,
and I would disagree with that and I can prove it just by asking a simple
question.
Do you believe that rape is wrong?
Do you believe the Holocaust was a bad thing?
Was antebellum slavery something that should have been reviled?
And the answer we all hold if we're decent human beings is yes,
all of those are objectively wrong.
Well,
how do we know you can't put it in a test tube?
We know because it's a revelation of the apostle Paul,
one of the greatest philosophers in human history,
I would argue,
suggested in Romans that this is the truth of God laid on every human heart.
Others have argued the Catholic Church and whatnot,
that it's natural law,
common sense,
the revelation that causes both of us to agree,
both of us to agree it's slavery is a bad thing.
No,
it's not open for debate.
We don't have to test it in a tube.
We know slavery should be reviled.
All right?
There's a lot there.
That's a,
that's bouncing around some of the ideas that I talk about here.
So basically without that,
that bedrock,
let's,
we'll do these backwards.
So we'll start with the fourth without that bedrock that everything then would
be left to some sort of subjective nature,
right?
That that's the crux of that.
Well,
so [inaudible] digresses to power.
Yeah.
If you don't have a principal and enduring permanent,
immutable principal,
it all digresses to power and we see that it's proven in human history.
I'm fond of telling my students at Oklahoma Wesleyan University,
in fact,
I often give the commencement address in May.
It's often very short.
I'd give them a gift.
It's a guaranteed standing ovation,
by the way,
to tell everybody before the speech starts that this'll be five minutes Max,
a five minute commenced by all.
Yes,
yes.
Go.
Now they're listened to me.
They want to celebrate,
but what I tell them often,
and it's a repeat almost every year today,
I'm not going to celebrate your opinion.
In fact today,
I don't care what your opinion is and you shouldn't care about my opinion.
I'm not going to patch on the back.
When you cry,
when you walk across the stage and approach me and you're funny,
cap and gown and me standing there in mind,
I'm not going to hand you a diploma and say,
congratulations.
You've got a degree in opinions.
That's absurd.
I hope you paid $35,000 a year to learn something.
That's right.
And Justin real and true.
True.
Something closer to the truth of your discipline than what you knew,
knew,
knew when you came in as an 18 year old four years ago,
and the proof to that,
you know,
some people may say,
well,
that's just your opinion on education.
Good for you.
Well,
I'll say this,
opinions always enslave,
but truth sets you free.
Pol Pot had an opinion.
Mao had an opinion,
ropes here and Chavez and Hitler and Mussolini,
all the despots of history had opinions and it didn't end well for millions of
people,
but Christ said,
you shall know the truth and the truth shall set you free.
There's power in the immutable,
unchangeable truths that set us free and there's always bondage in the opinion.
So what do you make then of sort of what I would say are the well intended
progressive's and I'm not,
I think there are some people without good intentions,
maybe at the top of that,
but I think the average young person that you're probably encountering as a
freshman,
uh,
that has been sort of indoctrinated with these ideas
that
follows through with them.
Like what,
what are the ways that you've been able to,
to sort of wake them up to why this is wrong?
Why,
why opinion based learning is wrong,
why they're actually are facts,
why,
why that matters?
Well,
I find the progressive mind and the progressive agenda is so easy to knock down
by a rhetorical question.
In fact,
uh,
again,
obviously in this interview thus far I've showed my cards.
I'm a committed Christian.
Yeah.
I believe the words of Christ make a difference.
In fact,
George McDonald wants say,
and my sister once said in my attempt to obey the words recorded as his,
I have found grandeur beyond the realm of any human invention and therefore I
cast my lot with those of the crucified.
That's good stuff.
So what do I do?
Well,
what if I believe that this guy named Jesus was actually who he claimed to be?
I'd have to kind of conclude that he's probably the smartest guy that ever
walked the face of the earth.
He knew the answer,
he knew how to win the debate.
But often this guy that millions,
if not billions of people have claimed to be God incarnate that walked among us,
didn't engage in an argument.
I mean you read the story of Christ and he almost never argued with his
opponent.
He could have won the debate.
He knew how he could have crushed them.
I would conclude but he never argued.
What did he do?
He asked a simple question,
which one of you wants to throw the first stone?
Why do you call me Lord?
Whose faces on this coin?
And then he shuts up and he lets the worldview of his adversary implode as they
dropped their stones and they walk away.
So what do you do with the post modern?
The progressive question from a 20 year old,
well,
can you tolerate my intolerance?
Do you hate hateful people?
Are you sure that nothing is?
Sure.
Do you know that nothing can be known and are you absolutely confident there are
no absolutes and then just shut up and listen.
They don't have an answer.
They saw off the branch upon which they sit and it comes tumbling down and it's
at that point I think you can rebuild the argument with some common sense rather
than this nihilism and nonsense literal nonsense because it makes no sense for
you or me to look and adversary in the eye and say,
I can't tolerate your intolerance.
It makes you the very thing that you find intolerable.
It's self shooting.
I feel like you're a sort of like a college administrator from the future.
This is sort of like the terminator.
You've come back to warn us about what's going on,
what's going to happen in the future here.
So let's,
let's back up a little bit,
just tell me a little bit more about how you got interested in these ideas.
Were,
were you always sort of political?
Did,
did freedom and liberty and ideas always matter to you?
Was that something you were taught?
Oh,
well you can now you've asked a question that could take way too long to answer.
So let me try to discipline myself to be brief.
I was a blue collar kid.
My mom and dad didn't graduate from high school.
My Dad was a truck driver.
My mom was a nurse's aide and a stay at home mom,
odd jobs here and there.
Uh,
we were lower middle class where it was paid to paycheck to paycheck.
when I graduated from high school,
I went to work in an apple orchard with some migrant workers and I also worked
in a local factory.
I did two jobs and uh,
working third shift lunch,
which,
what time is third shift for a,
I think that's three o'clock in the morning or something.
Like that.
Uh,
I sat down for lunch one night and this gentleman who was working two jobs,
he was a private business owner.
He had a flower shop,
so he was working the factory to help make payroll.
Wow.
But he had a master's degree in international politics or affairs or something
like that.
Esoteric degree.
And he looked at me over the picnic table and the factor and he said,
why are you here?
And I said,
to make money like you,
and he still,
why don't you go to college?
So I washed off the grease and I got in my expensive factory rat car that I
could afford as an 18 year old kid.
And I drove up the road a half hour and enrolled at a a Christian Liberal Arts
college that,
uh,
I was aware of.
And the rest is history.
Those doors opened up for me to be able to do things like,
be on this show and challenge one another with some reasonable debate and good
thinking.
Those doors.
Oh.
But opened up because of a classical liberal education,
not a progressive one,
not a left,
just one,
but a classical liberal education that liberated me to move into various
different venues of life that I never would have met,
able to do otherwise.
So as it stands now,
are you kind of shocked at the state of what's going on with young people at
colleges?
I mean,
the whole,
the whole purpose of your book,
right?
That it's become daycare sort of,
or some basic training session for students or things that they should have
learned a long time before that.
Not that you should know everything today.
You walk into college because of course you're supposed to learn,
but that they've missed a series of extremely important ideas before they've
even got there.
He is that,
was that when you first realized that was happening?
A,
when was that?
And B,
were you shocked?
No,
I'm not shocked because I've been seeing it coming for decades.
And you're,
you're,
you're accused of being an alarmist.
When you warn people of these things,
I'll,
that'll never happen.
Well,
where are we right now?
So when did you first see sentences?
I've been a college president for 16 years.
I would say about the time,
maybe 20 years ago when I was a vice president and various different,
uh,
various different segments within the academy.
I could see the shutting down before closed mind.
The,
uh,
unwillingness to entertain anything that might challenge you and move you out of
your comfort zone.
Which way was it coming from?
Where's it coming from?
The students?
Or was it coming from faculty or was it coming from administration?
Was it coming in every direction?
And I think it's a,
I think it comes,
we've created our own monster.
In fact,
when I originally confronted this daycare thing,
um,
it's interesting,
if I may set the context for the daycare story,
is that fair segue?
Let's do it.
Um,
I like the guest that sets up their own segues.
Nice.
Okay.
So what's the daycare thing about?
So at Oklahoma Wesleyan University,
we still have required chapel every Wednesday and Friday.
All the students and the faculty are in Chapel.
Uh,
this particular day it was,
uh,
three years ago,
thanksgiving week,
thanksgiving week.
So just before the break,
one of my vice presidents was the speaker in chapel and I know this particular
guy very well obviously,
and I know he always speaks from a script.
He never had lips,
so it's always a 1520 minute homily at best.
And he's done and it's from a script will after he was done,
I wasn't in chapel that day,
I was working or something.
So anyway,
he called me after he was done and he said,
hey doctor Piper,
I need you to give you a heads up.
I had one of our own students today play the victimization card.
He came up to me after I was done with my chapel talk and he pointed his finger
in my chest and he said,
you offended me,
you singled me out and you single my peers out and I'll like it.
And I said to Kyle,
the VP that was calling me to give me this warning.
I said,
well,
what was your talk about?
I was wondering it,
was it political?
Was there sarcasm?
What was going on?
He said,
you won't believe this.
First Corinthians 13 now for those that don't remember,
first Corinthians 13 is the quintessential love chapter of the Bible.
Love is patient.
Love is kind.
You've probably heard it read at a thousand weddings.
Okay,
so I said what?
He said,
yeah,
I know I spoke on love today.
I'm a monster.
And we had one of our students that was offended by it and I said,
send me a copy of your speech.
Again,
knowing that he talks from a script or speaks from his grip and doesn't add Lib
I the new,
if I read it,
I'd find if there was anything offensive in it.
Did he throw in a joke?
Was there some off putting humor or sarcasm?
I read it.
Nothing.
First Corinthians 13 love is patient love is kind of 15 minute.
I'm only on love and I've got one of my kids offended by it.
So I wrote this article.
I've been writing for the local newspaper for the last 15 years or so,
and usually when I write for the Bartlesville examiner enterprise,
five people read it through people care on this week.
I wrote a little different.
This one on this one,
I was a little frustrated so I popped off my op Ed and I basically said young
man,
that feeling of discomfort you had when you heard that sermon,
it's called your conscience and you might want to attend to it.
And if you came here expecting us to coddle you rather than confront you,
if you think we're going to comfort you rather than challenge your character,
you're in the wrong place.
And then I went on for another 700 words or so and I concluded by saying my
land,
this is a university,
it's not a daycare.
We expect you to grow up.
And that article,
by the end of a week we can and a half,
three,
I had three and a half a million hits.
Yeah,
we're going to link to the article down below cause people,
people should read it.
Yeah,
no.
Here's the point and I don't know if I'm off task and I'll shut up and let show
you're doing your own segway.
[inaudible] I'm with you.
But here's the point.
When I wrote that three and a half million people paid attention to it.
By the way,
NBC today cited it as one of the top 10 news stories of 2015 it went nuts.
Canadian Broadcasting Corporation,
Oxford,
England,
uh,
drudge and Dreher and Limbaugh and Beck and conservatives and liberals and
procrastinates all covered it.
But college president that called out his students and said,
this is not a daycare.
Grow Up.
Why is this important?
What Graeme,
what Grandpa or dad or mom has hasn't said that to their kids.
I mean,
this was not rocket science.
This was not high scholarship.
I basically said what everybody was thinking.
So why did three and a half million care,
three and a half million people care?
Well,
here's,
we did a statistical analysis analysis internally out of the all the comments on
those three and a half million views.
What,
how many were positive and how many were negative?
97% were positive.
And this was on the Internet?
Yes.
Yeah.
97% were positive in 3% were negative.
The poster child for the positive.
Um,
the atheist from a very well known university in Florida.
Fulbright scholar writes me a letter and said,
Piper,
I read you're not a daycare thing,
period.
I went to your website to figure out who you are,
As an atheist,
I can easily dismiss your religion and your politics and I do,
period.
But on this issue,
thank you.
Kudos.
It needed to be said,
please carry on.
That guy knew he,
that we had created a monster.
It was our fault.
Our industry's fault.
The Academy,
the ivory tower has created this mess and he understood it and the monsters
turning around to consume him and he knows it.
You know who the poster child of the negative was?
The church.
Wow.
I'll show you.
Offended the poor kid.
You hurt his feelings.
So what,
what was the offense taken though?
Specifically?
You tell me.
He felt so uncomfortable.
Right?
But he never addressed that.
A specific,
no way.
He felt uncomfortable.
He felt that sermon was directed toward him.
Well,
maybe it was,
there was a time that where the church was supposed to confront those things
that are selfish and narcissistic and the self focus was supposed to be
corrected by selflessness and confession.
I actually said in my article,
I'm not going to start issuing trigger warnings before altar calls.
A good sermon is supposed to wake you up.
A good sermon is supposed to perhaps instill some guilt.
So he was offended because he felt guilty for not showing enough love.
So,
all right,
there's a lot there.
So let's,
let's talk about first this atheist professor in Florida for a moment.
What do you make of someone that can take a principled stand like that,
that in your view of the way they look at the world,
is missing sort of a critical piece,
or let's say one of those four quadrants that you discussed before.
What do you make of someone like that?
I assume,
uh,
and I've had a lot of discussions like this on a micro level.
You probably think he's,
I don't want to lead you too much here,
but you probably think he's a perfectly decent person who may be living a very
moral good life,
but at a macro level you see more of a societal problem.
Is that,
is that a Ferris?
Well,
I think ideas have consequences again,
and I would in no way suggest to people that disagree with my religion are all
immoral people.
I mean,
it doesn't take five minutes of research to prove to the contrary.
In fact,
um,
these,
uh,
folks that agreed with me in my article that when I say this atheist from the
University of x,
Y,Z ,
Florida agreed with me and was the poster child of that.
It's interesting.
Many within the secular community rather than the sacred community.
If you want to draw that distinction.
We're all about this message in my speaking until they figured out I was a
Christian and then it kind of went cold because Canadian broadcasting,
I could tell when they figured out that I thought the solution was to return to
what Chesterton called big laws that would give us the maximum amount of free
human freedom.
Whether you're Christian or whether you're not really,
you're agnostic angle kind of atheist or Buddhist or baptist.
It doesn't make a difference.
But these ideas that Chesterton defined as the big laws,
the simple laws and others,
likewise,
I would argue Adams and Jefferson and Washington would agree that these big laws
were contextualized to give everybody freedom,
not just those folks that went to church on the weekend.
And I would argue that history has proven that proven that true.
Even Martin Luther King Jr proved it in his letter from the Birmingham jail.
The context for the fight for freedom and justice was what?
The natural,
irrefutable,
common sense,
natural law of God.
That's what Mlk told us.
So we see these examples time and time again in our march for freedom.
You can't have freedom without offense.
Said gesture ton.
In fact,
Chesterton said,
if you want to bid,
build the biggest playground in the world.
This was one of his analogies.
Let's,
let's assume that this community,
this near neighborhood wants the biggest,
the best playground in all of the United States,
and you spend all of the money to create the bells and the whistles and all the
toys,
and you want the kids in this community to enjoy that playground.
Chesterton said,
build a fence because if you don't,
what'll happen one of two things.
Either you'll start policing these poor kids and haranguing them and yelling at
them and creating all these little rules to control them so that they are safe
within the playground or they'll run out into the highway and get killed.
So either way,
the kids will be restricted or hurt if you don't build a fence around the
playground.
It's the paradox of freedom and fences of liberty in law.
Yeah,
I mean there's a lot of current analogies there with,
you know,
obviously there's a debate in the country about having a physical wall at the
border right now.
And you can make an interesting analogy to what's happening in the digital space
where we were all,
we all had free access to all of these platforms and then they start censoring
different people.
And because there are no fences,
they put imaginary fences all over the place depending on who you are.
But you mentioned something really interesting there,
which is that he,
uh,
thought or that some of the people thought that your ideas were good until they
figure out that there's a link back to religion.
How much of that has been a struggle for you in sort of the more secular
academic world generally?
Maybe not at your university,
but when you talk to other academics who usually probably shy away from religion
or scripture,
that sort of thing.
Well,
it's always a challenge,
but I,
uh,
let's have a debate.
Are you really a classical liberal?
Are you an open mind?
My mind did academic,
do you want to pursue truth or do you want to construct it?
Do you want to protect your opinions?
Is that more important to you?
Then understanding what the answer is.
At the end of the day,
are we going to trust a referee on the game and if we don't trust the referee,
if we don't define the boundaries,
if we don't have some rules for the game,
it's chaos.
You can't play basketball without boundaries.
You can't play soccer without somebody blowing the whistle.
It's the paradox again of liberty in law.
If you're a musician,
you know this.
If you don't learn the rules of rhyme and rhythm and cadence,
you're not performing a concerto.
It's chaos and if you're an athlete,
if you don't discipline yourself to the rigor of the sport,
if you don't memorize the place,
if you don't attend to the rules,
if you don't pay attention to the coach,
if you don't go day in and day out,
even though you may not be that good yet,
you will never be able to be free to actually perform in the game.
And that paradox is relevant.
When we're having an academic or an intellectual or a political or theological
or whatever discussion and debate,
what are the higher standards for the discussion so that we can actually be free
to do this.
How much of this do you think boils down to what seems to be a degradation in
personal responsibility amongst young people in the last,
let's say 20 some odd years that there's more of an uh,
you know,
people are spending more time say playing video games and I say this is someone
that like I tried to get you to play playstation and a half hour ago.
Uh,
you know that I like video games,
but that people are spending all sorts of time doing things that are,
that are almost the,
the obvious success of a society that we have everything.
We really just have everything.
It doesn't mean that every individual has everything they want,
but you have the world at your fingertips all the time with the phone in your
pocket.
And that because of access to everything,
the personal responsibility part,
the part that says,
I got to go get that job.
And at three in the morning having third lunch and all of these things that that
has sort of just disappeared.
Well,
uh,
there are a variety of,
you could claim that the church is responsible for its own demise.
The schools are responsible for educating their own monster that's consuming
them right now.
You could also lay blame at the feet of parents that are helicopter parents and
they don't allow their kid to feel or sense or experience any adversity in life.
We're going to coddle,
we're going to come comfort.
We're never going to confront and build character.
We're just going to make life easy for our kids.
And I see that over and over again.
When the parents drop their kids off at my campus,
I can tell you in five minutes where the kid's going to be a problem or not
based on how the parent is behaving.
Is Mom angry because doesn't like the drapes and the dorm?
Um,
do they attend to every single desire that the kid has?
If the kid ever has any conflict or with a roommate,
I want,
I want it.
I want it changed now rather than forcing their son or daughter to deal with
relational conflict conflict and become a more mature human being.
As a result,
the helicopter parenting is greatly responsible for a lot of the softness of the
soul and softness of our culture.
If um,
uh,
it's called the agon agony steeze the reg wrestling match,
if there's no ag on,
if there's no agonist,
if there's no wrestling match,
if there's no agony,
that's where we get the word.
Then you're going to be soft as iron sharpens iron.
One man sharpens another.
There is testing by fire is as we become adults in life and if that testing
hasn't taken place,
you're not going to perform on the field.
You're not going to perform in the band or in the orchestra.
You're not going to perform in a variety of venues in life because you expect
everything to be comfortable.
Yeah.
Or in the intellectual battle.
I mean,
I mean that's the point that,
well that's why I try,
I do try to link this back to personal responsibility,
whether ultimately it's from helicopter parenting or a poor education system
where a series of things,
because if you've,
if you've seeded that personal responsibility,
then all of the offerings that,
that say the left offers now have free this free that take from some give to
others.
They all,
it all sounds really great because you've already abdicated your responsibility
as a human.
So that seems to me to be the core issue if we could just get these young people
to wake up.
So okay,
so a kid walks in to your school,
moms complaining about the drapes,
the kid doesn't like his roommate,
whatever the other series of things are.
Um,
are you actually personally involved at any point in this?
Or tell me just a little bit about how the structure of the university works so
that you can get some of these ideas across.
Oklahoma Wesleyan is a small institution or about 1500 total.
All in that's healthy for us.
You know that's a financially healthy institution,
but it's got the magic of community.
You're not lost as a number and you actually engage with the phd.
You don't just get an education in classroom of 800 to 2000 students.
Who are you being taught by the graduate assistant that doesn't care.
We've got a ratio of one to 15 one to 16 and you're actually learning from the
scholar,
which I would argue as good education as opposed to somehow inferior education
just because you're smaller than the big guy down the street.
I think we've lost the power of education as we've started worshiping this altar
of size and the behemoth and the football program and whatnot,
that somehow is better education than actually learning like this.
Come on.
That's ridiculous.
In fact,
if you go to Oxford now,
all of the various different ancient colleges are really not much bigger than
Oklahoma Westland.
They've just been around for a thousand years.
Yeah,
there is.
It's pretty incredible.
I've been there twice in the last year I spoke there,
which was probably the biggest honor I've ever had professionally.
And then I went back with a Jordan Peter's in a couple months ago.
Exactly.
And it's shocking when you see that these small colleges,
the way they say it's,
it's so brilliant actually,
that they set it up with all of these small colleges in this,
in this truly,
I mean,
it feels magical.
It feels like a Harry Potter book,
this magical little place.
It's just incredible.
Well,
and it's good education because you're being taught by somebody who has wrestled
being agon for years and years and years,
and he may disagree with you vehemently,
but that Socratic method draws the conversation to a close where if you're going
to disagree with the scholar,
you better know apply and you'd better be able to defend it.
Otherwise,
he will challenge you,
tear you down,
and send you back to do your homework so that you can come again another day to
carry on the battle.
That's good education.
It's not soft education,
it's not coddling education at elevates the value of confrontation.
It elevates the goal of actually being a responsible human being at the end of
the day.
That actually has character more than just wanting a career in the United
States.
We think that somehow good education is one that just gives you the ability to
get a career.
I don't disparage that you should be able to get a good job,
but really is that where we are in the United States where information is more
important than ethics and money is more important than morality.
And getting a career is more important than character.
There was a time not that long ago where all of those things were important in a
liberal education because we wouldn't be free as a culture without.
So what went wrong there?
W when,
when did that go wrong?
Well,
you could argue that it preceded weavers work in 1948.
I would argue it goes back to duty.
Do we?
And the model of education that prevailed at that time where we stopped caring
about the,
uh,
the Socratic logic and the facts of education.
We started caring more about the feelings that come with education and the
common core debate.
And I'll really get people stirred up with this common core as a joke.
Why in the world would we want to dumb down education to the common,
to the average?
Don't we believe that education should pursue what's excellent and exceptional?
Common core puts everything at the,
uh,
at the,
at a level,
a level table of average,
of common.
That's why it's called that.
It doesn't release my faculty and others to do what they know how to do best.
I don't need the government telling my faculty how to build a syllabus.
I just don't need that.
If I have hired a math professor that doesn't know,
two plus two is four,
there's a solution.
I fire him and I go get somebody who knows how to come to the right conclusion.
I don't need someone else trying to intrude and govern that discussion.
And Oklahoma Wesleyan faculty has been ranked by CBS News Money Watch as having
the best faculty in the nation for three successive years by student review,
by student review.
So why in the world with the Fed thinks they need to tell me how to structure
education.
So what's the structure?
We do it small,
we can engage as a faculty and as an administrative body to develop a curriculum
that works because I hire scholars and educators that know what they're doing
and we have dialogue and relationships with the students as we get them to
pursue truth.
That's one of the cornerstones of our mission statement.
You pursue truth,
you don't construct it and at the end of the day you practice wisdom,
you practice what you preach,
you just don't have the cognitive and the intellectual.
You actually develop into a person of character that engages culture with
integrity.
Do you find that you get other administrators,
other school presidents and board members and probably donors,
all sorts of things from other schools that are reaching out to you going,
how do we fix this mess?
Because I find now that it's people ask,
I mean this has come up on the show many times.
It's like how do you fix this thing?
And it seems like it really can't come from the academics because they been sort
of in it too long.
And uh,
you mentioned to me briefly before we started how they're,
they're often not brave and we should explore that a little bit,
but that it really has to come from the donors that only when the money starts
getting cut off,
will the schools be willing to do the right thing?
But I assume people look at you and see what's going on and go,
that's what we should be replicating.
Well,
some do,
but not any industry protects its own.
And until there's a huge crisis,
people are never forced to change.
And I'm not sure we've reached that point of crises in the educational industry
in the United States yet.
We will.
Yeah.
Do you know,
what do you think that would look like?
Actually,
because I think a lot of people are watching this going,
we're in the midst of it.
The crisis is here.
It is here intellectually.
It is here morally it,
I mean you see it in the snowflake rebellion.
This is education where they're going to protest.
Ben Shapiro at Berkeley and Berkeley supposed to be the birthplace of the free
speech movement.
Basically protesting the guy who,
who says the same things that Ronald Reagan said that were mainstream
conservative ideas.
They're protesting a Jew and
calling him a Nazi.
This is an upside down claim that makes no sense and anybody with half a brain
can figure that out,
but yet Berkeley Silences Ben Shapiro and others because of what they don't
like,
his ideas.
That's not the birthplace of free speech.
That's ideological fascism that is not academic freedom.
In fact,
where do we get the word fascism?
It comes from the root word fast east.
A fascist was a Roman bundle of sticks that was bound together so tightly that
it could not be broken.
You see it in a lot of the freeze work in the sculptures in the United States,
the Supreme Court,
and in our capital.
You see a fascist,
which often has a hatchet head in the top of it.
What does it,
what does it represent?
The power of the bond,
the common bond,
which isn't necessarily bad,
but it's from that we get the word fascism that you must be one of us.
You must look like us.
You must think like us.
You must walk like us.
You must talk like us or your verboten.
You will be expelled.
We will crush you.
Berkeley,
Ben Shapiro.
We will crush you with the fascist.
It's intellectual.
It's ideological fascism that is not academic freedom.
It's the antithesis of a classical,
the liberal.
Hmm.
So I'm curious,
uh,
Peter Boghossian,
who you may know,
he's a professor up at Portland state who I've had on the show a few times and
just did these fo academic papers.
We have him on again in a couple of weeks.
He calls this postmodern set of ideas a secular religion because it has all the
markings of a religion,
but there's no redemption narrative.
And certainly if you're a white,
cisgendered,
heterosexual Christian male,
you better bow forever and never challenge it because you,
you have original sin basically.
Um,
I don't know that you've thought about that specifically,
but do you like that as someone that comes from a religious perspective?
Do you like that framing of this that it has the markings of religion in,
in a negative sense?
Let's say,
I would argue every worldview has the marketing software religion,
either positive or negative.
Um,
I don't think there's any way you can get outside of the box of a religious
discussion.
You and I might disagree on that at another time,
another place.
But I think everything is going to boil down to these key questions.
Origin of man,
nature of Man,
redemption of man and responsibility of man.
And all of those are religious questions.
Where do we come from?
What is our nature,
what of,
what does our redemption,
how do you fix the problem?
And then what is our responsibility at the end of the day,
that's another quad,
if you will.
Quadral lateral for things through which every human being sifts his worldview
in terms of trying to resolve how to function with one another and within life.
Postmodernity um,
I'm going to butcher this.
Historically,
anybody out there that's a good historian is going to just fingernails on a
chalkboard.
Don't worry.
We've got youtube commenters and they'll gladly teach here.
I'm sure you're doing,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
Um,
I'm gonna separate human history into three simple categories.
Premodern,
modern and postmodern.
What's premodern supernatural in pre modern,
there was this idea that truth could be experienced.
This is real.
This table is empirically verifiable.
I can touch it,
I can see it,
I can feel it.
But there were other things in pre modernity,
there were also real and those were revealed truths.
Mosaic Law for example,
there was a revelation that gave truth too,
man.
So premodern was supernatural.
Maternity comes along and it became what?
Simply natural premodern supernatural maternity.
Simply natural.
If you can't taste it,
touch it,
see it,
feel it,
then it just isn't so pre modern,
modern.
So what's post maternity?
If prematurity is supernatural and modernity is simply natural,
what's post maternity superman?
The ubermensch we shall rise up.
We will decide,
we will define,
we will declare ourselves to be as God.
The original sin is defined in genesis.
We don't need anybody telling us what to do.
Now,
whenever humanity comes to that point,
what always happens?
Good power.
Yeah.
Power crushes,
descent.
Premodern supernatural modernity.
Simply natural.
Postmodernity the Ubermensch Superman.
And I would argue that's where we are right now.
So how
dangerous,
uh,
or precarious,
let's say,
of a position do you think we're actually in,
in the United States right now?
We're just,
let's say the West in general,
because this idea is growing.
We're fighting it back there.
It's,
you know,
there's,
there's definitely some push back online.
But if you look at academia,
if you look at the political establishment,
uh,
if you look at the media,
these ideas are gaining and gaining strength.
If you look at the way the media treats the ideas of Alexandria,
Ocozzio Cortez,
they're making it seem like these are all the hot right ideas.
These are pretty radical socialist ideas.
Uh,
but they have incredible amount of momentum right now.
What kind of position do you think we're actually in right now at the beginning
of 2019?
Well,
I'm an optimist.
I,
I believe,
I know the end of the story and we,
when truth will prevail at the end of the day,
what happens between now and then?
Uh,
that's a matter of discussion.
In fact,
I had an old boss,
he was the president of my Alma Mater.
I worked for him as a vice president and,
uh,
he was afraid of flying.
And one day I pulled Dr. Chapman aside and I said,
what is the deal?
I said,
you're a Christian.
You're deeply committed.
Uh,
why are you so afraid of flying?
You know what the end of the story is?
He says,
I'm not afraid of the end of the story.
I'm just afraid of what happens between 30,000 feet in one.
I don't relish that two minutes.
So what's going to happen in that two minute gap of history?
I don't know.
I'm not a prophet,
but what I can say is these ideas are dangerous and they're nothing to just
dismiss.
And if you're a classical liberal that disagrees with my religion and my
politics,
if you're a classical liberal that wants liberty at the end of the day,
you better pay attention to this debate because you have things that I just
looked at this morning on the news before I came here where Nancy Pelosi is
proposing that laws should be in play,
that if parents are parenting improperly as defined by her and her party,
that the government should actually have the right to take the child away.
So if I've got a 10 year old boy and the way he's behaving sexually is something
that I think is unhealthy for him,
should I have the right as a parent to pursue council for him or should the
government be able to intrude and tell me no,
you don't have the latitude to parent that 10 year old boy the way you want to.
Those discussions are in play right now.
And again,
if you disagree with my religion and my politics,
that should bother you because religion and politics will change.
The power base will change and what's popular today won't be popular tomorrow
and then you'll be on the losing end.
You better care about something more permanent and enduring.
Immunable true.
The devastating consequences of abandoning truth.
Truth will set you free,
not Nancy Pelosi.
Huh.
Well,
I think that we got the Promo for this episode.
I right there.
Um,
how enthused to you that these discussions are happening also outside of the
academic world right now?
You mentioned that Jordan Peterson,
you reference him in your book that would,
that this guy's on this world tour.
I happened to be on it with him.
Uh,
but that these conversations,
even with some guys that maybe you don't agree with on a,
on a believer side of things,
say a Sam Harris or the rest of this,
this crew,
um,
that people really care about these discussions where I would say five years ago
people online were,
you know,
people were watching cat videos and people be in,
kicked in the nuts and a couple of other things,
but they weren't really having the discussions and now they're,
they're on fire online.
So that,
that's pretty helpful.
Well,
I do think it's helpful and again,
if you trust truth,
if you trust the referee,
if you trust the whistle,
then play,
throw elbows,
rebound,
knock people over,
do what she need to do.
Trusting that the game can be played.
And I think that's the magic of the conservative Worldview,
the conservation of those big ideas that allow you to engage.
That's the beauty of the traditional Liberal Arts Academy Trust truth to win.
The irony here.
I had somebody,
when Milo hit his a snafu a couple of years ago,
somebody called me up and said,
are you going to have milo at your campus?
Because he had been dismissed from Berkeley or wherever it was?
And I said,
no,
because I don't agree with Milo on so much that I don't want to lead anybody to
conclude that somehow I'm elevating his ideas to some level of acceptability
within our culture.
I said,
how are you?
Let me pause here.
So if a student,
if the student group on campus had invited him,
would you have allowed that to proceed?
If that's a little bit different than someone asking you,
will you have him?
If a student or a student group wanted to discuss his ideas,
I let's go at it.
Those ideas can be discussed robustly and you'll engage with our faculty and the
rest of the community and vetting those ideas.
Who's right,
who's wrong?
There are some times when,
here's an example.
Let's get off mile for a second for me to answer this question.
I had another gentleman who's very well known and very popular across the nation
who,
um,
wanted to speak at our,
at my commencement,
but he's of a different religion
now.
Had he accepted my invitation,
which I,
uh,
issued to be part of a day of cold belligerence Francis Schaffer,
where he and an evangelical,
a Catholic conservative Jew would have come to the table to have a discussion in
front of the students in terms of how to be co belligerent for a common good of
common sense and common morality.
Pick a topic,
uh,
the preservation of the sanctity of human life.
That would've been a great thing.
But putting somebody that disagrees so much with the core tenants of my
institution at my pulpit,
at my podium on the key event of the year,
commencement is something that I guard because it sends a signal to everybody.
Um,
so I didn't,
I didn't invite him to the commencement.
I invited him to a day of cold belligerence.
Does that make sense?
Yeah,
yeah.
So on,
let's get,
you know,
I'll defend your right as a,
as a private institution to do what you think is best.
But let's get back to Milo.
Would I put Milo at the podium at the pulpit?
I think I have to guard the message of what we stand for.
Missionally right.
But would I put him in a different venue where there would be debate and
disagreement and I'm good exchange.
Uh,
that's a different question.
If that answers you.
And I suspect the answer is yes to that.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah,
possibly.
I mean,
I'm going to make a decision.
There are some people I'm not going to because they're so far outside the pail.
Uh,
I'm not going to put a white supremacist on my podium because I think it's
offensive to,
I mean,
we were birthed out of the civil rights movement.
We were actually birthed,
the Wesleyan church was an abolitionist church.
We took a stand against slavery.
So our history,
our mission is human equality.
And it's,
uh,
it's,
we stood in the face of the civil war and said,
no,
we will not do this.
And it's out of that.
We birthed ourselves out of the episcopal Methodist church and became the
Wesleyan church because orange gotten,
Luther.
Lee believed that it was wrong to call a human being less than a human being.
The definition,
the Tamago Day of what it meant to be human was something that they would not
prefer that ne for fit.
And they held on tenaciously to that definition,
thus the Wesleyan church.
So am I going to put somebody at my podium that refutes all of that?
Uh,
I'll,
it's a judgment call
that I have,
so,
right.
Interesting.
Do you think that universities,
you probably don't want to say this as a,
as an administrator,
but that perhaps the way learning relative to people watching videos on youtube
and conversing online and all of these things that the way young people are
learning is changing so rapidly that 10 years from now or 20 years from now,
that the university system is going to be either completely different.
I think that's a foregone conclusion perhaps,
but not just different,
but far less relevant that you will have figured out ways to learn in many other
ways.
I mean,
I say this all the time now.
It's like if you just watch this show,
not that it's a complete version of what you should get in college,
obviously,
but you can have,
you know,
uh,
behavioral scientists and evolutionary biologists and clergyman and a wide set
of people from different walks of life.
You can learn from them.
And if you want,
you can get a pretty damn good education that way.
That's not the complete piece of why you should be a college.
But do you sense that that's really
changing?
Oh,
there's no question.
I mean,
you've got micro Glenn back.
Um,
Tucker Carlson all have been very aggressive in the last six months on advising
parents not to send their kids to college because of the flaws of the academy.
This daycare,
not in sense the lack of robust debate,
the debt that you're incurring to get a terrible education.
That's basically indoctrination rather than intellectual half-ton inquiry.
And I don't necessarily disagree with them.
I think there are a handful of institutions left that care,
but literally,
I'm not sure it's much greater than a handful.
So yes,
education would change.
But here's the shame of it.
When it changes and becomes more online and I'm technologically driven,
you're going to lose this,
and if you lose this,
you lose half of what education is about.
If these same ideas were expressed from a distance in an email exchange or an a
text exchange,
or if you saw me speaking,
uh,
online,
you might think that guy's a jackass because we haven't had that.
Maybe you think that anything we haven't had the opportunity to actually develop
a relationship.
Relationships are part of the core and the soul of good education.
That's what causes you to become part of the human community.
Part of being a human being as the relationship and if all we're going to do is
transfer information through the internet rather than engage in a relationship
that actually builds to common understanding of those revealed truths that
matter,
we've lost the core of what it means to be an educated person in a liberally
educated human being.
Yeah.
You know,
it's funny,
I'm so intimately aware of that because in the last year,
especially where I've been on the road so much,
I see one set of ideas online and a certain amount of hate and anger and
resentment and all,
all of that.
And then everywhere I go,
and I mean this without exception,
I meet great people just like this.
And you,
you talk to somebody and it's,
it's so much more powerful than the,
the conversation online.
So even though I'm so
enthused about people getting ideas from these conversations and things like
that,
yeah.
The other part of that and,
and maybe colleges will shift and learn to integrate some of that.
I hope.
I suspect financial pressures,
pressures are huge right now.
Uh,
I think Forbes put out an article less than a month ago that caught,
that suggested that 50% of all colleges and universities in the nation will
close in the next 10 years because of the financial pressures.
And as a college president,
I understand why Forbes is predicting that.
I would argue that the handful that will succeed are those that are clear and
bold and distinct.
The marshmallow,
the Mush,
the vanilla will fail.
Now,
you may disagree with my Christian paradigm.
You may disagree with the four pillars of Oklahoma Wesleyan University,
which are the primacy of Christ,
the priority of scripture,
the pursuit of truth,
and the practice of wisdom.
That's who we are.
We have a center for capitalism,
free enterprise and constitutional liberty.
We are pro life where the only university in the nation that operates a mobile
ultrasound clinic,
free of charge to women in our 102 hundred mile radius.
We've saved over 200 lives as a result of doing that.
Now,
how many college presidents are you going to hear the story from?
Very few and people listening right now may say,
I don't want that.
Fine.
Go get what you want.
It's a free market,
but those that are listening right now that like it,
they're not going to find any place else and they'll knock down my door to buy
it.
Nobody wants vanilla ice cream.
If you sell a flavor that's bold and distinct and clear and different,
the people that want it,
we'll buy it.
Missional clarity is critical for any industry,
any business,
and especially for the academy right now because if we're all just vanilla mush,
then why would you pay twice what you need to to get an education from me when
you could go down the road to the junior college and get the exact same thing.
It makes no sense.
You've got to be distinct,
otherwise you fail.
Can you talk a little bit about how the uh,
sort of the new studies say gender studies and women's studies and things like
that have kind of infiltrated the,
the,
uh,
more traditional disciplines that,
that seems to be a big word lately.
Okay.
Now you're pushing me here.
So,
um,
uh,
I'm going to answer clearly.
I'll let you do your own segways for awhile.
So
I'm going to answer clearly.
Uh,
it's a compromise of the dignity of the woman,
pure and simple,
who's losing right now in the academic discussion?
Women,
why do I say that?
Okay.
Title Nine is a 1972 law that was established to give women equal access to the
field,
to the shower,
to the scholarship,
to the bathroom,
to the sport.
Good.
Right.
Okay.
We've complied with that started good.
We've complied with that since day one.
Now,
under Obama,
I receive a letter like every single college prison in nation received demanding
through a bureaucratic Fiat,
not through legislation.
That's a different discussion that we immediately start providing transgender
accommodations on our campus.
I responded and I said,
no,
no.
Why did I do that?
Because I'm not sympathetic to those that are wrestling with that just for you
or that particular issue of life.
Now I'm not.
That's not why I said no.
I responded because I said this and I actually put it in writing.
How can I possibly comply with title nine which you doe and OCR telling me I
have to do if I now deny the biological fact of the female and start pretending
that women aren't an objective reality,
but rather a social construct?
Who's going to lose?
If I do this,
Mr Doe and Mister OCR women are going to lose.
They're going to lose their scholarship,
lose their sport,
lose their competitive advantage because they're going to be supplanted by men
who take it away from them.
And by the way,
we see this now in sports all the time,
every,
every witness is not hypothetical,
is another wrestler,
Trans woman wrestler that's beating a biological woman.
And people are cheering this as if this is the way it's supposed to.
And how was that fair and how is that pro woman?
The irony again is as a conservative,
I'm the classical feminist now because I'm acknowledging the feminine and I'm
saying that women are real,
they're not a social construct.
There are biological fact,
and they should have the protections that title nine afforded to them back in
1972 and I refuse to compromise that.
So I sent a letter back to the doe and the LCR and I said,
no,
told them why.
And I received a letter back saying,
you're exempt.
Wow.
At which point I got criticized robustly as you can imagine from anybody that
disagreed with my particular defense of the dignity of the woman.
But you got the exemption.
I did for now.
Well,
now both.
Now title nine has changed because of the Trump administration.
So each title,
they're just enforcing it and the more pure way rather than trying to manipulate
it through bureaucratic Fiat.
Yeah.
Um,
the same thing was true on a affordable care act.
Oklahoma Wesleyan,
um,
stood with the little sisters of the poor on the steps of the Supreme Court in
defending the right of a bunch of nuns to not have to buy contraception.
They're celibate.
Why do they need any stop and think?
Yeah,
why should they have to buy any contraception?
And how does it possibly pro woman for the federal government or anybody to tell
these women what kind of products they have to purchase them,
their health care package.
When they don't want them,
they won't use them.
They don't need them.
And by the way,
they're Catholic,
they're prolife.
So the Fed intrudes into all of that and says,
you've got to do this.
You've got to buy this product.
By the way,
Oklahoma Wesleyan,
by definition,
hires only prolife faculty and staff.
So the women at Oak who are pro life too,
they're not Catholic,
but they're pro life who can possibly claim to be pro woman and ignore the
wisdom and the intelligence and the right to choose that these women should have
in their health care.
We were the ones that defended that we were the only university in the nation to
challenge the,
um,
a bureaucratic Fiat that suggested on sexual harassment that you have to convene
a kangaroo court on your campus,
that you've now are required by law to circumvent the local legal channels and
persecute the accused on your campus by not allowing him to be adjudicated by
people that actually know what they're doing.
Local law professionals in the courts,
and it also compromise the rights of the woman,
the rights of the accuser because you drunk,
you were then required to drag her before a committee of her peers and go
through the whole thing again.
It's,
it's just completely bananas.
I mean,
we're,
we're eliminating due process or that's exactly,
exactly.
Oklahoma Wesleyan was the only university in the nation of Christian
conservative institution stood up and said,
no,
we will not do that.
Fire actually represented us and I was thrown out and we prevailed.
Hmm.
Okay.
All right,
I got one more for Ya.
Okay.
There is a 1617 year old watching this right now thinking about what college
they're going to go to.
I think you've done a pretty solid sales job already,
but give them the final sales job of why they should attend Oklahoma Wesleyan.
We'll decide what you want.
Okay,
so first of all,
what product do you want?
Do you want a career?
Do you want technical training?
Do you want,
I'm an apprenticeship.
Then you might not want to go to Oklahoma Wesleyan if those are the only things
that you're interested in.
If you also want to wrestle with the big ideas,
if you also want to do it robustly within the 100 year tradition of a classical
liberal arts education,
which is not progressive and leftist,
but grounded in those time tested trues,
you might want to consider coming here and again,
I've got to throw this in.
I can't ignore this.
We are Christian.
If you want those four things that I described,
the primacy of Christ because we believe he is who he claimed to be the prior of
scripture.
We believe that the Bible is more than just an interesting dusty book.
Okay?
We believe that it contains the revelation of those truths that actually give us
the ability to do this.
The pursuit of truth.
Truth is an objective reality rather than just a postmodern construct.
I'm not going to give you a diplomate and opinions.
I'm going to give you a diploma that demonstrates you learn something.
And then finally,
the practice of wisdom.
The practice of what you preach.
We're integrationists head and heart fact and faith,
belief and behavior.
Personal Life and public life are integrated.
We're not segregationists.
We don't separate things that should be United.
I'm the president of a university.
I'm not the president of I die.
Versiti and there's a reason for that.
The unity of Vera tasks,
the unity virtue,
the unity of the verities,
the Yuna versity is historically something that celebrated us coming together in
unity,
bound together by truth with a capital t.
It didn't degrade and vulcanized culture and humanity into division.
We should be teaching virtue and Veritas not victimization and when you teach
victimization,
you get advice and you get vengeance and you get violence.
That's what you see in the protests in the streets right now.
The solution to anybody that's listening to me is get an education in the
virtues in Veritas.
In truth,
it's more than a career.
It's about something that actually builds your character.
This is the first interview I've ever done where I wish I had to get into the
intellectual dark web card that I could just hand you right now because it's,
this has been a pleasure just sitting with someone with a complete set of ideas
that that knows what they think and is a master at it.
I've,
I've thoroughly enjoyed this.
I hope you have as well and for more on Doctor Piper,
you can follow him on Twitter.
Yeah.
He's on Twitter for better or worse,
it's Dr. Everett Piper.